in 22 States workers will get a raise
this year as new minimum wage laws take
effect but what if I told you those laws
hurt the very people they claim to
protect when wages are forced to rise
businesses must offset the cost so here
are three reasons minimum wage hikes are
a bad idea one Higher prices with
already thin profit margins businesses
pass higher labor costs onto customers
two reduced work hours one study found a
3% wage increase resulted in a 9%
reduction in hours work and three fewer
jobs thanks to automation via robots and
kiosks here's proof California passed a
law setting a $20 hourly wage for most
fast food workers in response Pizza had
announced it would lay off 1,200
delivery drivers supporters of minimum
wage hikes claim no one can live on 725
an hour but in reality very few do only
1.3% of hourly workers make minimum wage
or less and of those roughly half are
under the age of 25 it's why minimum
wage hikes hurt teens especially black
teens the most minimum wage laws tell
Americans they are better off unemployed
than what a business can afford which is
why famed Economist Thomas Sol says the
real minimum wage is always zero